our next guest is a Super Bowl champion
television host and fun fact at 6'5 the
tallest person to ever fly into space is
Michael
Michaels
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
how are you
you are approaching the one-year
anniversary of going to space I mean
come up what I watched you
but like what was going through your
head what or your body what did it are
you like oh I'll tell you this I wasn't
worried about it when I said yes until a
week before
and then I said what did I sign up for
right but we but the thing is we had
been promoting it so I'm like is it too
late to back out oh my God you just just
like described my constant mental state
sure I'll do that mental gymnastics
mental gymnastics mental gymnastics yeah
and I was worried about that but by the
time they did such an incredible job by
making sure we were ready simulating
everything by the time we got to that
day and you're on the rocket and they're
counting down
yeah that that was all the bravado
before the flight like if they had taken
a picture like right before the flight I
was like
did you bring anything special with you
I took my Super Bowl ring I took my NFL
Hall of Fame ring I took my my
grandmother's uh my mom gave me a
stopwatch from her father my grandfather
so I took everything at very personal
um that meant something because
you know the most fascinating incredible
thing I've ever done and we give us a
little pouch that we they stuff under
our seat and I brought something for you
that went to space with me it's very
simple don't get too excited
that actually was on the ship with us
that was in my purse no that is yours no
really that is the first one I've ever
given anyone
I haven't given anybody any of those so
but I appreciate you
now your father was in the military and
you grew up in Germany yeah the I I I I
spent some time there I was curious like
what because when you came back to the
States that's when you got into football
yeah what did you take from Germany like
the little possessions Memento that you
took up to space what did you bring back
what changed you what stuck with you
about living in Germany like in your
upbringing it was the mentality that you
know my dad being in the military we
started on a military base so around a
bunch of Americans in a foreign country
and you'd need each other but then my
dad retired and for the next 15 16 years
we lived off base within the German
community and you learned that people
even though they're in a different
country they're just like you people
just want to be loved respected and you
have to learn to get along with people
and respect people in their culture in
the way that they do things and I think
that that Outlook of being around all
different people no matter what race
religion or whatever social social
background Financial background that we
we all really can co-exist if we really
want to yeah and so I I kind of look at
I treat people like I want to be treated
I make sure that I don't care who you
are I don't care what you got I'm going
to respect you because everyone wants to
feel valuable yes and in the world
everybody wants to feel they have some
value and that's what I learned from
living in Germany well that really
speaks volumes about exactly who we know
that you are so that is an origin story
thank you um okay growing up you used to
do Jane Fonda workouts I tell you what
Jane Fonda saved my life really yes I
was 13 years old I was 13 years old my
brothers and their friends called me Bob
which meant booty on back big old butt
and and
I found the James Fonda VHS tapes and
they saved my life and it was the first
time that I saw if you don't like
something about your life No One's Gonna
Save you no one's going to change it for
you you have to do it yourself and Jane
Fonda helped me do that she really did
um all right you had an interesting
pre-game routine what was your pregame
ritual I used to talk to my socks okay
well you want me to demonstrate I mean
I'll demonstrate exactly how it would go
I would get
I would get to the locker room
and I would put my grab my socks and I
would look at them and I would go which
one which one which one of you should be
on the right foot huh you would you like
the right foot okay let me see and then
I would get it halfway on sometimes and
go no no you don't like to write I'm
sorry I'm sorry you like the left foot
because I felt if I did my socks would
if I didn't put the right sock on the
right foot I would be off balance and
now I see socks would right and left in
the r and an l and I'm like I'm the head
of my time
they stole my idea
I'm really happy to now know what the
ritual looks like thank you for sharing
it yeah I'm about to go smash into 300
pound guy and I'm here worried about a
left and a right sock but that's that's
kind of how it was hey you got to do
what you got to do 100 speaking of you
got to do what you got to do I have met
your beautiful daughters you're very
nice to them oh I love them I I I I I
got like I I was worried they were gonna
think I was um well too much because I'm
a too much kind of person but because I
have two daughters and they're both so
lovely I just kind of got right in there
and was talking to them I don't think
you knew who they were I don't you
didn't know who they were I did not know
they were your daughters you didn't know
they were my daughter no and we happen
to be in the same place taking a little
break
um and they came back to the house and
they're like Drew Barrymore talk to us
for a long time today Dan they were so
excited and I'm like yes he's really
sweet and really nice and then I saw you
and you talked about and I saw you with
your daughter and it was like it was you
know you were so nice and just brought
such light and just to see my kids come
back and see someone that they admire to
meet them in person is not always you
know the best thing sometimes but me you
in person is better than anybody can
expect so thank you for being so nice
yeah they're they're awesome they're so
special and cool and thoughtful and of
course because I have two girls I was
like tell me everything I need to know
about sisters you know I'm on constant
research mode but boy are they so lovely
come on constant referee mode
I mean are they how old are they now
they will be 18 on the 28th of this
month they are seniors in high school
and they couldn't be any different and
it's tough I mean you got daughters and
they boyfriends what do I do what am I
what because I feel like I'm gonna have
a taser an NDA a chastity belt a
background check how am I supposed to
navigate
anyone dating my daughter I'm gay right
now it is not dude when I tell you it is
not easy it has taken everything in me
not to walk in there and said what do
you want like I even at one point I was
gonna put on my football uniform uniform
full uniform put the stuff under the
eyes like put water on my face come down
like I was sweating and hitting people
like who are you
then you know it's a line that Howie
Long where I work with that fox told me
this line and I've used it I said I just
want you to know son I'll do the time
let you know
well I have to say they are such good
girls and you're raising your family so
beautifully and you take care of people
and now I love this new Endeavor I
cannot wait to discuss it with you you
are doing men's skin care I also love
the name daily defense yes defense I
double entender yes
foreign
[Music]